many say don't punch down when talking
about people like Chris sununu or sloppy
Chris Christie or Ada Hutchinson I call
him Ada not ASA because of certain
reasons
or others but sometimes it's necessary
to talk badly about those that for no
reason other than politics speak badly
about you otherwise
the people that love you don't know
whether or not they're for real are they
saying the truth they're not so
sometimes you have to punch down and you
have to say what's happening otherwise
they won't understand it's not fair to
them you have to put them
in proper perspective these bad people
you have to put them in their place
anyone who says something slightly
negative has to become an enemy because
then in the minds of his followers it's
really easy to think okay I don't have
to listen to the very accurate
criticisms coming from Chris Christie
because he's an enemy he's in the enemy
category he's sloppy Chris Christie